crois pas l'homme où la femme de sa vie
y est tous les deux on a fini par se
l'avouer bon a vraiment que toi mais
j'ai envie de voir du monde aujourd'hui
on peut très bien vivre une vie
complètement normale en étant homosexuel
amour de dieu me suffit je pense s'il
n'y a pas de sexe je m'en fous c'est pas
grave et le début je lui ai dit si notre
couple y tient si dure longtemps je vois
pas de problème à ce qu'un jour tu vas y
expérimenter de la suite a dit qu'il
faut pour nous je tends à de plus en
plus à ce que mon handicap prennent
place dans mon existence dès qu'on parle
de sexualité on parle pour l'instant on
parle de pénétration tout de suite
qu'est ce qu'un couple en 2022 le sexe
est il indispensable le mariage est il
toujours une étape importante regarder
du porno en couple est ce normal ou
encore faut-il respecter toujours les
volontés de sa famille celle-ci hugo
j'espère que vous allez bien un an après
le dernier épisode on se retrouve pour
un nouvel épisode d'hexagone alors
hexagone qu'est ce que c'est peut-être
pour les nouveaux en gros c'est un
format avec six jeunes aux opinions et
aux parcours très différents qui
viennent discuter dans un cadre bien
veillant à propos d'une grande
thématique est aujourd'hui bien on parle
des relations amoureuses et avant de
commencer je tiens d'ailleurs à
remercier froots qui a accepté de
soutenir ce projet en étant partenaire
de la vidéo dont je pense que j'ai pas
besoin aujourd'hui de présenter froots
vous le savez c'est une application de
rencontre qui permet de trouver la
personne qui vous correspond grâce à un
système de fruits donc que vous
recherchiez le grand amour une amitié ou
alors autre chose ça fait quand même un
moment maintenant qu'on travaille
ensemble et qui soutiennent notre
travail ils le font encore aujourd'hui
l'envi donc avec cette vidéo vous allez
le voir c'est d'en faire un lieu
d'expression où chacun peut vraiment
s'affranchir des tabous ou alors des
clichés qui peuvent encore exister dans
les relations amoureuses et d'être en
quelque sorte un miroir de la société et
surtout les biens de relations qui sont
belles à partir du moment où elles sont
assumés et consentante et fritz donc
rejoint cet objectif bref un grand merci
à fritz pour son soutien n'hésitez pas à
checker le lien en descriptions jamais
vous voulez découvrir l'application et
je vous laisse tout de suite avec la
vidéo
pour vous un couple c'est forcément deux
personnes je sais très bien que ce n'est
pas le cas pour tout le monde mais j'ai
jamais envisagé l'amour autrement que
avec une personne qui m'était cher ce
qui peut être paradoxal mais
mais c'est j'ai jamais aimé personne
d'autre que la personne avec qui j'étais
et ça me paraît impossible
surtout après des expériences que j'ai
eues en couple ouvert bonjour je
m'appelle paul j'ai 22 ans je suis
étudiant en informatique et avec ma
copine on a été en couple ouvert pendant
trois ans et aujourd'hui on est toujours
en relation mais plus en relation libre
plus en couple ouvert on a décidé
d'arrêter dès l'ouverture du couple on
était tous les deux d'accord sur le fait
que je n'aime que toi personne d'autre
j'ai envie d'avoir d'autres expériences
parce que c'était voilà on était tous
les deux très jeunes on s'entend de
manière charnelle alors voilà mais c'est
à dire que vraiment on a fait déjà la
distinction entre amour et sexualité et
ensuite
on était tous les deux d'accord pour
dire que voilà c'est il ya toi dans ma
vie il ya des personnes avec qui je
couche mais il ya toi qui est la
personne avec qui je veux faire ma vie
on s'est mis ensemble on était vraiment
bas à très très jeune mais on était
quand même assez jeune on était tous les
deux mineurs et bat tous les deux on
avait eu très très peu d'expérience
sexuelle et donc tous les deux on a fini
par se l'avouer bon je t'aime vraiment
que toi on et j'ai envie de voir du
monde j'ai envie de voir le vin j'ai
envie voir le monde j'arrive voir ce que
les gens peuvent m'offrir ce que
d'autres personnes perdent moi de me
proposer qu est-ce qu est-ce que
qu'est-ce que c'est la sexualité avec
d'autres personnes pourquoi est-ce que
pourquoi le monde quoi vraiment essayer
de comprendre un petit peu comment ça se
passait je me vois que dans un couple
autres kim est fermé comme ça en aucun
cas
mais
chacun son avis et je respecte ceux qui
sont couple libre bonjour je m'appelle
syrie j'ai 22 ans je suis étudiant en
informatique et je suis de confession
protestante moi comme j'ai jamais été
amoureuse en fait en l'occurrence je me
rends pas compte de ce que c'est
deux bars en fait mon coeur bat pour une
personne est à la fois j'arrive à
toucher un autre corps moi j'ai un
rapport à l'intimité ou depuis peu ou
c'est très liée aux émotions sentiments
même plus que les émotions d'ailleurs et
et je ne vais peut-être plus maintenant
en tout cas avoir une relation intime
avec quelqu'un alors que mon coeur pense
à quelqu'un d'autre mais pas mon corps
bonjour je m'appelle mélanie j'ai 23 ans
je suis en psychologie et j'entends bien
aujourd'hui en tant que personne et
terreau porteuses de handicap donc une
hémiplégie congénitale c'est à dire qu'à
la naissance j'ai eu un manque d'oxygène
au niveau du cerveau qui fait que
l'hémisphère gauche de mon cerveau n'a
pas capté la partie droite de mon corps
la liberté n'est pas toujours la même
dans chaque couple qu'on va pas dire moi
je vais me sentir libre ça se trouve
pour t'accompagner ça sera couple livre
que toi tu l'as fait alors que pour moi
couple libre enfin la liberté dans mon
couple ça sera être que nous de faim et
c'est pour ça que avec ma copine en tout
cas la communication et la liberté c'est
les deux termes les plus importants je
m'appelle max ans j'ai 19 ans je suis en
études de sciences politiques que je
suis en couple depuis neuf mois avec une
femme je suis non binaire et on est dans
un couple ni libre ni exclusion est
alors moi j'ai eu beaucoup de relations
enfin beaucoup
j'ai eu des relations avant ma copine
donc je savais ce que ça faisait d'avoir
des relations avec d'autres femmes je
savais ce que c'était qu'une relation
que les relations lesbiennes alors que
elle elle était sortie au enfin tout cas
elle ne connaissait pas les relations
avec les femmes et on a eu une
discussion au bout de quelques mois
alors comme ça ça fait pas hyper
longtemps qu'on est en couple ça fait
que neuf mois et dès le début je lui ai
dit si notre couple y tiens c'est dure
longtemps
moi je ne vois pas je vois pas de
problème à ce qu'un jour tu va
expérimenter parce que je sais que je
suis ta première relation et je veux pas
que tu gardes une rancoeur envers moi et
que tu te sentes enfermé alors que le
couple c'est censé être la liberté moi
je trouve quand même qu'il ya un hic
autour de ce concept de
de liberté je trouve qu'en bat on est
dans une génération où il ya vraiment
une démocratisation de la sexualité de
l'amour et je trouve ça ultra chouette
en revanche moi il ya quelque chose
enfin pas que je suis encore dans un
truc ultra conventionnelle loin de là
mais en fait y'a vraiment cette cité
aussi où le fait d'ouvrir son couple
c'est vraiment vu comme réponse pour
instaurer la liberté dans le couple non
pas tu as normalement si chacun existe
pleinement sans ceinture et elles sont
quelconques oms toxiques qu'elles libre
dans un courrier elle m'a jamais demandé
mais c'est finalement la liberté dans un
couple dans l'amour ce ne se résout pas
à la sexualité est tellement dans une
démocratisation du sexe qu'en fait les
sexes et limite le fondement du couple
mais je trouve ça assez problématique
parce qu'en fait il ya des couples qui
sont monogames depuis 20 ans et sont
limite plus libre que des gens qui sont
dans une fausse liberté qui est assez
vaine finalement tu as parfaitement
raison parce que justement il ya
beaucoup de gens qui se sentent poussés
comme comme tu disais qu'ils sont
poussés à être en couple au lit parce
que pour eux c'est ça la liberté alors
que pas du tout justement comme tu
l'avais dit il ya des gens qui sont plus
libres en couple monogame et moi
aujourd'hui je me sens plus libre
qu'avant elle m'a jamais dit ouvertement
moi je me sente à niveau dans notre
couple je lui ai dit si tu as le besoin
eh ben on en discute en gros c'est ça
moi je dis pas notre liberté doit se
fonder sur la sexualité non moi la
liberté elle se fonde sur la
communication et sur nos besoins six
mois ça ne fait pas plaisir que tu as
couché avec d'autres gens elle ne le
fera pas et on en discutera on trouve à
d'autres solutions est ce que le sexe
est indispensable dans un couple on
pense pas que le sexe responsables
chacun sa libido chacun à ses envies
différentes bonjour je m'appelle louana
j'ai 23 ans je suis en animation 3d je
suis en couple depuis trois ans et demi
et je me définis comme à sexuelle moi je
me considère comme demi ace donc à
sexuelle mais je pourrais avoir des
relations sexuelles uniquement avec des
gens où il ya vraiment un profond
feeling une connexion assez forte du
coup c'est ce qui se passe avec mon
copain mais de manière générale s'il n'y
a pas de sexe je m'en fous c'est pas
grave c'est la vie
ennemis je m'en porte mieux parce que
des fois tu peux te sentir un peu forcé
à cause de la pression qu'il ya autour
en mode haut mais vous faites pas ça
vous fait vous ne le faites pas trois
fois par semaine vous n'êtes pas dans
dans les dents les règles d'un couple ça
où les potes qui te disent mais le
pauvre sûr
mais non je pense pas du tout serein
persan bien sûr y en a qui sexualité
très haute limite de très hautes qui
voudront le faire une ou deux fois par
jour mais ça c'est leur problème de son
côté jeu forcément il ya un peu
d'adaptation parce que il ya peut-être
moins à un moment où je me forçais un
peu pour lui faire plaisir surtout il ya
eu des moments où pour moi c'était assez
compliqué parce que je voulais pas lui
montrer que ça me faisait chier quoi de
me forcer un peu mais petit à petit
notamment avec les confinements et tout
parce qu'on était ensemble ont été bons
pendant les de confinement ont été
bloqués en somme on va dire et c'est
juste là où je me suis nommé je vais été
si j'ai pas envie je lui dis non et puis
c'est tout françois il m'a jamais forcée
rien du tout c'est toujours moi qui me
forçais pour lui parce que j'avais de la
peine pour lui pour pour sa libido de sa
chanson que ce soit indispensable
mois pour donner mon exemple quand j'ai
décidé de m'investir dans une relation
plutôt longue
les personnes que je rencontre et avec
qui on avait un début de connexion je
leur imposer de ne pas avoir de sexe
pendant un mois c'est en fait ce parti
du principe que si pendant un mois il
peut se retenir
non mais c'est qu'on est déjà sur des
bonnes bases et où on va d'abord
apprendre à se connaître les entreprises
on va passer à d'autres choses et j'en
ai perdu plein
et par des blancs mais tant mieux et
j'ai fait du tri chez beaucoup de tri et
j'en ai trouvé un qui est mon copain
actuel
avec qui on a d'abord aimer nos
personnalités pourtant on est vraiment
totalement opposé on a d'abord humaine
aux personnalités avant d'émettre chose
c'est ce que je recherche je voulais
d'abord créé d'abord aller a par contre
aujourd'hui je vois pas mon couple sans
sexualité comme moi s'est pas posée
puisque peut-être gêné vis d'autres où
tout ou pas d'ailleurs mais je vois pas
mon couple sans sexualité bonjour je
m'appelle maxence j'ai 25 ans je suis
cadre dans l'immobilier et je suis en
couple depuis six ans avec un homme je
rajouterais que
on remplace dans mon cas je remplacerais
aussi la sexualité par autre chose
c'est-à-dire les moments d'intimité avec
zelda dans un costume qui sont pas du
sexe du coup ça peut être des moments à
deux justes même des câlins du curling
en face nice alors ça ça me suffit
largement aux jeux dit non on regarde un
film c'est super on est là dans les
moments à deux passes et qui beaucoup
plus important est que je saurai où on
se balade énormément je suis entièrement
d'accord avec toi parce que dès qu'on
parle de sexualité on parle fort sans
qu'on parle de pénétration tout de suite
alors dans la section et il ya tellement
de choses
oui non mais ok mais il ya plein de
choses en fait dans la sexualité c'est
pas forcément que l'acte sexuel donc moi
je te rejoins énormément sur ce que tu
viens de dire sur le fait qu'on ya
d'autres choses dans la sexualité que
l'acte réel faire l'amour quoi
typiquement ma copine je ne parle pas de
préliminaires c'est déjà du sexe ont dit
samedi pas préliminaire ce n'est pas
très classe élite et c'est déjà
effectivement le mariage et c'est
toujours une étape importante pour vous
oui c'est une étape importante
mais même si je n'ai pas encore trouvé
la bonne personne pour l'instant mais
c'est un acte symbolique c'est sarah
jour on se remémore les gens disent
c'est le plus beau jour de leur vie mais
oui moi je voudrais me marier un jour et
pourquoi pas après avoir un enfant et
fonder une famille il ya un aspect
religieux aussi parce que
le mariage c'est quelque chose qui est
important c'est
sert en fait c'est après la naissance ya
aussi le mariage du coup c'est comme une
sorte de deuxième naissance en fait on
continue on commence une vie avec
quelqu'un d'autre et je trouve ça
fascinant le mariage mois avant je
pensais sincèrement jamais mariée puis
ce que j'imaginais dans ma tête que
c'était le mariage l'enfant et le kangoo
et je n'avais pas du tout envie de cette
villa est en fait finalement après j'ai
revu un peu quand même position je
considère que on peut avoir envie de se
marier mais je considère pas du tout ça
comme une finalité est pas du tout ça
comme étant quelque chose de très
important dans un couple je crois
sincèrement en fait que l'amour est
possible mais dans mon imaginaire je
crois pas à l'homme où la femme de sa
vie en fait potentiellement je vais
mourir un jour et donc je serai
accompagné à ce moment là donc ça sera
l'homme de ma vie et mes dents
imaginaire la qualité de la rencontre ne
se trouve pas dans la course mais dans
la distance plus tôt mais dans la
qualité du moment même et des fois les
relations elles sont faites pour sa
portée 10 ans de bonheur comme des fois
huit mois mais en fait d'un point de vue
qualitatif ça se vaut tout autant et en
fait forcément j'ai pas envie de me
marier parce que non pas que je projette
en la personne le fait que ça va se
finir mais il ya un peu un côté
poétiquement de fatalis de à moins que
je meurs je sais que potentiellement on
n'a pas vivre 45 ans ensemble puisque
ont évolué et en évoluant je vais avoir
d'autres attentes et envies de me
construire avec une autre personne et
notre âme en l'occurrence moi mes
parents n'ont jamais été mariés ce qui
fait que j'ai j'avais beaucoup de mal
avec le concept de mariage parce que
pour enfin mes parents se sont séparés
tous mes amis en tout cas leurs parents
soient censés variable pour moi c'était
très compliqué même temps je rejoins
thierry terry
est ce que ben moi j'ai été très
chrétienne pendant longtemps donc j'ai
été éduqué dans le catholicisme et j'ai
en fait j'aime beaucoup les religions
mais quand je me suis rendu compte donc
que j'aimais les femmes et que ça allait
contre ce que dieu disait eh bien ma
première réaction c'était d'aller me
confesser aux prêtres et en fait ça m'a
brisé le coeur de me dire j'aime la
religion et la religion même pas en tant
que personne parce que je rentre pas
dans la case dieu est censé être
représentés partout tout le monde et au
final je lui plais pas simplement parce
que mon amour est différent de celui des
autres et donc ça m'a mis une grosse
barrière sur le mariage puisque je me
suis dit mais en fait je rejette la
religion vue qu'elle me rejette je vois
pas pourquoi je l'accepterai et donc le
mariage avait pour moi était une pas une
question ensuite j'ai rencontré ma
copine et je me suis dit mais en fait je
l'aimais tellement que oui un jour c'est
ça marche je veux me marier et je veux
passer ma vie avec elle parce que je
suis encore jeune et j'ai le droit
d'avoir de l'espoir sur l'amour qu'on
est ensemble et j'ai le droit de me dire
je veux que ça marche et je veux que ça
tienne et je veux que ça dure longtemps
en amour et ce qu'il faut respecter les
volontés de sa famille moi je fais
plutôt à penser ne respectent rien non
mais ne respecte rien hormis les en tout
cas pour rester la famille ne respecte
rien fait à vie comme toi tout le sens
caen visite
de voir ta vie comme la façon dont on a
envie d'être heureux la personne avec
qui tu veux partager ta vie il faut pas
accepter de pression et
des valeurs mais je n'aime pas forcément
sont pas tous chemins des valeurs
musulmanes mais finalement ça s'est un
peu retourné en rythme quand j'ai fait
mon coming out j'avais évidemment
extrêmement encore pour deux raisons la
religion mais je venais d'une famille on
va pas se le cacher une famille noire
c'est compliqué à la simili parce qu'en
plus on n'en parle pas j'ai jamais eu de
pression autour du fait de faut qu'il
soit hétéro jamais alors moi jamais dit
il faut que marine etc par contre
en fait c'est quelque chose qu'on
ressent je me sentais pas libre de
pouvoir être homosexuel dans ma famille
et est notamment
s'est très mal passé enfin passer
pendant un an c'était très compliqué
avec mon frère et
finalement
par la suite il sait convertir à la
religion musulmane et j'ai appris que
c'est par ce biais là il m'a accepté
alors je pense l inverse quand j'ai fait
mon coming out je l'annonçais chez chez
une voisine qui était une amie d'enfance
et j'avais fait mon sac en disant je
vais faire de votre venue en fait
j'avais tellement peur de ça je les fais
à 18 ans pour être sûr que les choix
majeurs et en disant je fais mon sac et
si jamais il me dit de partir de chez
moi j'ai déjà trouvé notre maison
et quand il est dit en l'occurrence ce
jour là avec mon père
il veut enfin lui aussi un peu tombé des
nues et puis il m'a dit ça va être
compliqué pour toi enfin potentiellement
tu vas peut-être heurter à des
homophobes
ce soit dans le travail dans la rue
toutes ces choses là et est aujourd'hui
à 25 ans je peux le prouver inverse et
il a mis un an
l'accepter à faire son chemin puisque en
fait je peux comprendre voilà
il m'a jamais rogné il m'a toujours
offert un toit toujours offert à manger
et au bout d'un an il a commencé à
l'accepter il ya m'autorise à ramener un
copain quand il m'a autorisé ça que je
savais que du coup voilà il avait fait
son chemin qu'il avait il avait bien
compris
je pense qu'il a besoin même un peu plus
que normalement en vérité mais ce qu'il
faut c'est ce compte dans ce que tu dis
est servat de la réaction taille la plus
part des autres que de toi en fait ce
n'est pas tant l'homosexualité qui lui
fait peur ou qui ou qui dépréciait c'est
vraiment les gens c'est là le problème
en fait en fait ils avaient peur que je
mène une vie compliquée qu'aujourd'hui
on peut très bien vivre une vie
complètement normale en étant homosexuel
il reste de la discrimination à
l'embauché les choses comme ça mais
beaucoup beaucoup moins qu'ils avaient
avant et j'ai aujourd'hui moi je peux le
prouver totalement inverse de façon
aujourd'hui comme ils me voient je suis
assez fan oui je le sais faire plein de
projets et aujourd'hui il est persuadé
que qu'on peut réussir sa vie
normalement sans être emmerdé en tout en
étant homosexuel ou lesbiennes comme un
hétéro classique d'un de mes grands
parents
alors que je pensais que beaucoup rien à
voir de la religion mais je pensais que
ayant l'âge qu'ils ont ça va être
compliqué pour lui de l'accepter et ça a
été totalement en fait j'étais de
surprise en surprise mais sincèrement je
pensais que mon frère allait très bien
l'accepter ça a été très compliqué pour
l'heure non je savais que mon père je
pensais qu'on parlait me jeter dehors il
m'a passé le terrain voilà j'étais de
surprise en surprise et
j'ai vécu ce que j'ai vécu mais
aujourd'hui ça a forgé le caractère que
que j'ai et la détermination quand là
que j'ai pu avoir été en caucus regarder
du porno alors qu'on est en couple est
ce normal je suis addict porno depuis
très longtemps depuis que j'ai accès à
un ordinateur je regarde du porno et je
regarde de manière maladive
et je suis en sevrage en ce moment à
bougie 3,6 dans quatre semaines quatre
semaines ça fait quatre semaines et 2
jours que j'ai arrêté complètement le
porno je compte les jours c'est
extrêmement dur et je me rends compte à
quel point le porno est une
maladie pour la société c'est pour moi
c'est quelque chose d'absolument
terrible et j'ai jamais considéré que le
porno été trompée avec ma copine bon
bien sûr arriver la nature de notre
relation qui faisait que c'était plus
facile mais c'était au delà de ça c'est
à dire que même avant qu'on soit en
couple ouvert et même après j'ai jamais
considéré que le porno soit trompé avec
ma copine jamais considéré que le fait
que l regard du porno soit un problème
mais en fait c'est même pas une même pas
vis-à-vis d'elle que ça me pose problème
pour moi le porno est un problème en soi
vis-à-vis de soi-même que lorsqu'on
regarde du porno se fait du mal à soi
même on se donne des fausses idées même
si on sait tous que ce ne prononcez pas
la vérité si le format du port nous le
bien le même s'il ya du porno éthique le
porno éthique c'est super sauf que ça ne
suffit pas d addicts je le sais et j'en
ai je regardais et je pense même pas je
m'ennuie sur du pronostic mais c'est
vrai et c'est terrible et mais parce que
je suis un et l'ict ça a détruit ma
libido et alors heureusement je les très
bien vécu avec ma copine parce que c'est
pas que du sexe entre nous je vais
d'ailleurs très bien vécu avec elle et
ses portes pendant un moment j'ai même
dit que c'était peut-être pas tant un
problème que ça ça rend les moments même
intime
plus fade parce que c'est ma copine
c'est de la personne la plus importante
de ma vie est ce que j en train de vivre
qui est une expérience magnifique et
fade
eh ben j'arrête le porno pourront que
pour en fait pour que mon cerveau
reviennent à la normale parce que ce qui
se passe dans le port ne sais même pas
ce qu'ils fassent dans le porno que tu
regardes lorsque tu as un addict c'est
même pas agréable pour qui que ce soit
moi dans mon cas de personnes à sexuelle
je ne regarde pas de porno ça m'a jamais
attiré au contraire ça me dégoûte même
un peu mais je pense que c'est parce que
j'ai vraiment l'image du porno ça allait
tout donc je n'ai jamais regardé j'ai
jamais essayé de me masturber juste ça
ne m'intéresse pas mais par contre que
mon copain le temps que un billet qu'une
vidéo normal oui il le regarde et ça me
dérange pas enfin le début je peux être
envoyés au bon bah je te suffit pas
c'est comme ça mais en soi c'est un peu
vrai mais bah je vais le laisser faire
parce que ben déjà je suis personne pour
l'empêcher de regarder ce qu'il a envie
de regarder il fait ce qu'il veut et
c'est tant mieux si ça peut aussi le des
frustrés du fait de ne pas avoir
justement autant de relations sexuelles
qu'une personne un couple normal doivent
en avoir bah tant mieux vas-y fais toi
plaisir fois mais mais je veux pas le
savoir parce que ça me dégoûte un peu
car le porno ne reflète pas la vraie vie
comment la relation avec une personne et
tu pourrais accepter que tu accompagnes
regarde du porno par exemple oui mais je
préférerais ne pas le savoir en fait je
dirai
pas son jardin secret où il fait ce fait
ce que tu veux tu regardes ce que tu
veux mais ne le dis pas parce que en
fait ce que moi je suis pas là pour lui
dire des interdits ou des obligations
mais est-ce que
ça j'en attends le mariage est ce que tu
peux quand même à avoir des relations
seules fins sexuelles tout seul où ça
aussi tu n'as pas le droit de le faire
qu'avec une autre non franchement les
relations entre guillemets seul même ça
ça
m'attire pas en fait d'accord j'arrive à
et qu'est ce qui fait que tu aies pas à
sexuelle dans ce cas la fois je leur ai
posé la question
entre guillemets je pense que l'amour de
dieu me suffit je pense et ça me comble
dans ma vie et c'est pour ça que j'ai
pas une gp2 libido j'ai pas j'ai pas
d'attirance sexuelle ou
juste se rencontrer des gens ça me
suffit et trouver la bonne personne et
on verra par la chute non moi c'est
juste qu'en fait je renverse le sujet
ces juges jésus pour la masturbation et
je suis pour le fait que certaines
personnes d'imaginaire que d'autres et à
partir du moment où on a moins de
l'imaginaire bas je pense que ça serait
censuré les personnes et les discriminés
vont pas être veut dire donc créé des
propres images parce qu'on est tellement
dans un truc effréné autour de la
sexualité et notamment sur les réseaux
sociaux
non c'est ok il y en a qui vont déjà eu
moins d'expérience donc pas forcément
ils ont moins de référents imagé ou
auditif donc
moi c'est juste que j'en ai jamais trop
regarder parce que j'en ai quand j'en
avais regardé un peu ça m'avait pas
confrontés à des manquements et comme
tout ce qui va être kama sutra ça me
confronter plus à ce que je pouvais pas
faire que qu'un champ des possibles donc
j'ai vite arrêté mais mais en ce qui
concerne l'autre bah non c'est un pour
moi c'est un médium comme un autre tant
qu'il est éthique
selon vous est-ce que les opposés
s'attirent ou alors qui ressemble
s'assemble accompagnerez moi c'est
totalement l'inversé sur tous les sujets
c'est que moi je suis
j'aime faire la fête je n'aime pas faire
la fête je suis extraverti il est très
introverti je suis pas timide il est
timide
je suis très carriériste et pas tant
carriériste tout ça enfin voilà on est
vraiment opposés sur tous les sujets on
a quand même évidemment quelques sujets
en commun mais pour moi les opposés
s'attirent très sincèrement je le vis au
quotidien et même si on y opposer j'ai
jamais autant aimé quelqu'un
qui pense l inverse de moi c'est ma
balance finalement j'arrive à trouver
mon équilibre grâce à lui reçoit
exactement la même chose surtout le côté
balance mais après j'ai quand même une
petite réserve parce que en fait on a
quand même des bases communes et des
valeurs communes c'est à dire que je
ferai après évidemment je fais des
études en sciences politiques ou pour
moi la politique est super important
surtout pour une femme pour une personne
pour une personne lesbienne c'est de la
politique est très importante et je
pourrai pas sortir avec quelqu'un qui
n'a pas su pas qu'il n'a pas ces valeurs
là qui est d'extrême droite par exemple
je sais que je ne pourrai pas donc il
faut des valeurs et des bases communes
mais il me faut un caractère opposé au
mieux un tout petit problème sur la
relation qui se ressemble s'assemble
c'est que l'on peut tomber amoureux de
quelqu'un qui sait comme un deuxième
mois quoi un exemple de personnes têtu
ensemble ça s'embrouille tout le temps
de personnes jalouses et j'avoue que moi
je pense châtiera les puces les opposés
parce que par mon caractère mon
comportement j'ai quelqu'un de chill de
jeu marche lentement
du coup je vais faire c'est montrer
quelqu'un de plus speed plus à la va
vite entre guillemets et du coup il
comme ce sera une une balance pour moi
et non je préfère les opposés s'attirent
je pense c'est difficile à dire moi j'ai
expérimenté les deux et en grandissant
j'ai tout simplement essayé de
neutraliser cette idée de
d'opposer ou de ressemblance est
effectivement comme toi je suis revenu à
cette idée de valeurs communes qui a
permis d'élargir le champ des possibles
en terme de deux rencontres et
fructueuse après la question que je me
pose depuis la fin de la relation qu'il
ya eu un gros moment de communication au
sens noble du terme par rapport à moi
mais propre vulnérabilité
c'est que je j'aimerais sans pour autant
leur chercher mais essayez de
de trouver un quelqu'un qui me
ressemblent comme tu le disais par
rapport aux vielles compliqué est-ce que
là en fait je pense que je suis arrivé à
un stade où je me suis toujours interdit
de ressentir quoi que ce soit par peur
des prouver et pour avoir rencontré qui
a été la rencontre de ma vie que l'amant
récemment une personne une femme donc
même profil que moi qui a le même
handicap que moi ça a été tellement
salvateur et en fait c'est pour ça que
c'était sur la chouette c'est un parfait
prolongement de ce qui s'opèrent en moi
depuis deux semaines maintenant c'est
qu'en fait ça a totalement changé mon
art de communiquer puisque en fait
j'avais pas besoin de partir dans des la
lutte interminable pour expliquer la
douleur que c'est de vivre dans mon
corps et c'était assez incroyable
j'avais pas besoin de faire des
métaphores et j'avais pas besoin de
regarder intensément la personne dans
les yeux comme je le fais avec mes amis
ma famille pour qu'ils comprennent un
dixième de ce que c'est d'avoir un bras
qui répondent pas quand je le regarde et
en l'occurrence à
d'avoir quelqu'un qui me ressemblent ça
serait vraiment cette idée de
de faciliter joie de facilités parce
qu'en fait je me suis rendu compte que
s'il ya des limites on voit que les gens
ils peuvent s est le comprendre mais il
ya des limites à l'empathie ils peuvent
comprendre le ressenti et ça prend une
telle place et en fait je t'en a de plus
en plus à ce que mon handicap près une
place dans mon existence mais dans un
soupir en militantisme et j'ai besoin de
le partager avec mon partenaire voilà un
très très grand merci à tous les
participants d'avoir échangé aussi
ouvertement sur des sujets parfois très
intime et très personnelle merci à eux
et merci aussi à proust d'avoir
sponsoriser la vidéo la discussion se
poursuit donc dans les commentaires sous
la vidéo avec respect évidemment à la
dessus je compte sur vous si par
ailleurs vous aimez ce format et que
vous avez des idées de sujets à traiter
dans l'hexagone dites le moi directement
dans les commentaires ça peut pourquoi
pas nous permettre de trancher entre
plusieurs sujets sur lequel on hésite en
ce moment bref présent de vous présenter
aux proches et on se dit ah très vite